(audience cheering)
- Welcome back.
Congrats!
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] You're now co-host
- Yes.
- [Kelly] On "Dancing with the Stars."
- Yes. Co-host, it's crazy.
It's full circle moment.
- [Kelly] Are you excited?
It's, I think it's fun to host a show
cause it's like.
- Clearly.
- [Kelly] I mean even like
shows like that though,
I love, I love it's very quick pace
and especially if it's live
and it's awesome, yeah.
- It is, and I just have to
put it out first and foremost.
Like Tom Bergeron, from
the beginning when I was
on at 18, was always the most
kind, most beautiful soul.
Um yes, exactly.
(audience clapping)
And then, you know, all
the co-hosts previously.
Tyra and now Alfonso and
I are gonna be hosting
so, this is just gonna
be like coming back home.
- Is that crazy for you
just growing up on a show?
Like, I mean it's, this
you've been on this show since
the beginning.
- I was 18.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was on the show and you
know, I was a dancer first.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Julianne] Won my first
two seasons back to back.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's incredible.
- [Julianne] And then came back
as a judge and that was one
of the most like fulfilling moments.
And then of course to
come back now as a host
it just really does seem full circle.
Oh, that was like my
coming out party outfit.
That was like, that was
like, I have arrived.
- [Kelly] Look at me shine.
So, when they first asked you, I heard
that you actually said no.
- [Julianne] When I was 18, yes.
- When you were 18, yeah.
- Yeah, because I was
like you know, I wanna be
a respected actress and singer.
I don't wanna be on a competition show,
you know, dancing.
And then it was like.
- [Kelly] Because that can
get skewed in the public.
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
And like, I was like, you
know, this is what I wanna do.
This is my path.
And then it was like, well I
guess it's kind of a good thing
to be able to have that
as my day job, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah. And then it blew up.
- [Julianne] And then it blew up.
It was so wild.
I mean, like overnight I was, I had
just finished high school, basically.
And then I got on the show
and I mean, you know it.
- We have very similar starts.
Yeah. I was like, wait,
this sounds familiar.
- Yeah, like, in fact, we were
actually opposite each other.
It was like idle and, and Dancing
With the Stars were across
the hall from each other.
- Oh my gosh.
That is crazy.
- [Julianne] But obviously.
- You were different age.
- [Julianne] But obviously different time.
- Different time, yeah.
- I just have to say
that like from being on
the show to now, I've had the most support
and the most loyal fans from that show.
- So cool.
- And so, to be able to like
come back in a way that's like
just, I'm so full of gratitude and love,
like I cannot even begin
to share how excited I am.
- It's also that was
the experience, as well.
That doesn't always happen for
everybody, so it's awesome.
That was. But speaking of acting,
so, I asked your brother
this once, but you and, you
and he were in one of the
Harry Potter movies, right?
- That is correct.
- [Kelly] Just so, you know,
there will never be anything
you do that is cooler
than this to me.
- [Julianne] Oh, by the way.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Kelly] I'm like, I think
this is the coolest thing ever.
- You are not alone.
- That is crazy.
- The coolest thing ever.
- That would be my claim
to fame till I die.
(audience laughing)
Like, I love Harry Potter.
I love the whole, I read all the books,
and then I saw all the movies.
I love the whole world.
I think it's so creative.
- Samething, I just read all of the books
and then like, I was
going to school in London
at a performing arts school.
- [Kelly] I know that, yeah.
- And they came to our
school and we're like
we're doing this movie, but
we can't tell you what is is.
We all auditioned and stuff.
And then they told us it was Harry Potter.
And I remember I clearly was
American because I was like,
um, can I audition for Hermoine?
- Hermoine?
Oh my God.
It's very American.
I heard that you had a
crush on Daniel Radcliffe,
is that true?
- Oh, for sure. I was 11.
We were in Gloucester
share shooting a scene.
And I, and it was Valentine's Day,
and I actually got him a Beanie
Baby and like tried to like,
it was Valentino, wrote him a love note,
don't know if he ever got it.
I think I've told the story
a couple times, but in fact
I actually saw Emma Watson
the other day and I walked up
to her and I was like, hey.
Like we've met a few times,
but I don't know if you know
this, I was in Harry Potter.
She's like, I remember you.
I was like, you absolutely
don't remember me.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
I was an extra.
- Maybe she's got one of those memories.
- She was being kind.
(Julianne and audience laughing)
- I will say though, you're one
of those striking people though.
And it's a lot to do
with your eyes, ma'am.
So, once you meet you,
your eyes just stand out
especially when you're that blonde.
So, it's like, I don't know,
she might've remembered.
You're very striking.
- [Julianne] You're very kind too.
- Just saying.
No, I'm just saying.
You remember, you remember
something sometimes.
But, I have to, I have to
show this video your mom made.
I love your mom so much.
- Me too.
- [Kelly] This might be just
the best mom thing ever.
Watch this video.
(swoosh sound)
- And then I've got a place
for my essential oils.
I've got my earbuds, I
have some doggy treats.
And some of course some
cashews, some nuts, you know?
Cause I like to munch,
and you know, you never know
when you need some sunglasses.
Oh, I found another earbud.
Well, that's cool.
You never know what you
might find in these pockets.
I've been looking for those.
(audience clapping)
- I've been, I've been looking for those.
I was telling her while
we're watching this,
I love pockets.
I'm obsessed. If you see me to dress on
a red carpet or any event, it has pockets
and I have things in them.
- Oh yeah.
- Like, I love pockets too.
- Oh my gosh.
Anytime, like any of us see
pockets will like send a video
to my mom and be like,
mom, we're thinking of you.
But like, I don't know if you saw
the last thing when she opened
her jacket, she actually had
a Little Silly Sally Puppet.
She also does puppets.
- I know, I saw that.
- [Julianne] She's so cute.
- [Kelly] She's adorable.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- So, you brought wine today,
first of all, thank you.
And secondly, this is your label
and it's with Nina Dobrev, right?
- Yes. Yeah.
So, Nina and I Oh, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
- I'm about to go on vacation to Italy,
so just cheer to that.
- Just kinda get started early.
I love it.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna try it.
Yeah, my best friend Nina and I,
we started Fresh Vine Wine.
And you guys are gonna love this
because it is a premium
wine from Napa Valley
but, it's low carb, low
calorie, low sugars.
And honestly, like we've done
so well since we launched.
We are in, we're gonna be
in all 50 states by July,
which like.
- [Kelly] Wait, you've only
been out for like a year,
right?
- [Julianne] We launched in
2021, but we, in one year
we got all 50 states, which
like, that does not happen.
- Wow.
- [Julianne] So.
- It's really good.
- [Julianne] So, like
Whole Foods, total wines,
like it's everywhere.
And also, again, not
compromising on how good it is.
Because I've tasted some of
the other low calorie ones
and I'm not trying to knock,
but I'm also trying to promote, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But also something just
sometimes doesn't taste good.
So, you're not knocking it just, yeah.
You grew up in a Mormon family,
which I love your family.
I actually met your whole family one time
I feel like, in a
hallway, in an award show.
And I was like, your mother
should sell her eggs.
But like here, they're all beautiful.
It's like, what?
Anyway, but so wine was never probably
a part of your household.
I'm Southern Baptist, so
sometimes whenever I grew up
it was like no dancing, no singing,
like was often very footless.
- Very footless.
- That's hilarious.
Didn't even mean to do it.
But when did you start living wine?
Since, you didn't grow up around it?
- Well, when I was 21,
I actually ended up dating
your former host Ryan.
- Ryan Secrets.
- Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. And so we dated and
he's very much into wine.
And so he, it's,
- I didn't know this.
Oh yeah, he's got a, I think
like a winery in Napa
and in Italy and stuff.
- What?
- [Julianne] Yeah, like that was my first.
- He have so many jobs.
- [Julianne] Yes.
- Okay. Keep going. I'm sorry. Yeah.
- That's a total sidebar.
- Yeah, yes.
- But we, yeah, he like
introduced me to wine.
And what was so interesting is
like, because I didn't drink
you know, growing up LBS
it was usually associated
with like partying, getting drunk.
But this was like a, an education.
And I'm such a geek.
I love to learn.
- I love learning.
- And so it was like, he taught
me like all the different
like how to, you know,
smell and taste and like
swirl the glass.
Yeah.
- You know, like it was
very, it felt very cool.
And then, yeah.
And then I was like, how do
I take that, what I learned
and put it into something
good and share it
with all of you.
- Yes. Something wonderful.
Even Jesus was into this.
So I'm just.
(everyone laughing)
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] I'm doing God's.
This is God's plan, Drake.
This is God's plan, not mine.
Exactly. Thank you, Jesus.
I like water too.
But this was an, this was an improvement.
Well, last year was your Broadway debut.
Congratulations. That's so exciting.
- Thank you.
- I love Broadway.
- [Kelly] So, the play was
put on, was it all women?
- [Julianne] All women.
- That's cool.
- I mean, director, the writer.
There were seven of us
and it was all women.
Yeah. It was unbelievable.
Vanessa Williams, Susie Mcara.
And like, it was just amazing.
(audience clapping)
But the best part is
the title of the play.
So, the title is called Potus
or Behind Every Great Dumbass
or Seven Women Trying to Keep 'em Alive.
(everyone laughing)
- And it's like the longest
title, but it's extremely funny.
- It is. It's a farce.
And you know what was so
great about it is, you know?
Last year with everything going on.
I mean, politically it
was like, we thought we
were coming in to do a, a
comedy and at some point
like it switched and all of a
sudden it was very cathartic
and people were coming in
and it was so, like we were
in this moment of time and
history and it was just
the first time I've ever been
able to like really stand
for what I believe in through my art.
Instead of having to like,
you know, get on Instagram
and preach, you know, it was
like, this is what I believe in
and I get to do it through my art.
And that was really, really cool.
- And it's the coolest thing too.
To be able to do that with humor.
- [Julianne] Yes.
- Because that's how you,
you, you break the barrier.
I feel like between if any divisional kind
of thing happening.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- [Kelly] Any division
happening, I should say.
But it, I feel like that
humor just comes right in
to save the day.
And it's like, it makes
you kind of step back
and just see things
from different sides
and like a playful way.
- Well, and obviously it
can always get very heavy
and so the fact that
there was like a moment
where you could go to a
play and have real issues,
but you're laughing and feeling
so empowered when you leave.
Like that was so special.
- And thought-provoking, it's
cool to be part of something.
I assume that it is
thought-provoking and people leave.
- [Julianne] It is.
- Talking.
- It is.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, it is.
- Well, everyone has a story
about something not going right
like with a live show.
- [Julianne] Oh yeah.
- I have plenty.
(everyone laughing)
And I've shared a lot of them.
What is yours if like in a dancing thing
or whatever you're doing?
- [Julianne] Oh my gosh.
- Has anything ever gone very poorly?
- [Julianne] I mean,
wardrobe malfunctions.
Like up the yin yang, literally.
And like, I don't know.
I mean, I definitely
have not forgotten a line
but forgotten to speak and you know.
- [Kelly] Interesting.
- Like meaning like, I
just forgot it was my turn.
- Oh, okay.
- You know, and so like, there
was a pause and then, huh.
You know? Which is like the
biggest dream that you have.
Like nightmare.
- [Kelly] Nightmare. Yeah.
- That like, you forget your lines.
You can't sing like you're dancing
and you're falling on the
floor and you can't get
up. Like, those are my
nightmares by the way.
You're welcome.
Yeah. But that actually happened
on stage where I just like, I just froze.
Cause I was like, yeah, who's
supposed to speak right now?
- Why is it someone's failing here?
- Yeah. Someone sucks.
Not, oh, it's me.
- I forget lines all the time.
Like I, even whenever I was
like high school doing musical
like theater, like I, I always messed it.
I just kind of would improv it.
But I do the same thing musically.
I think my memory isn't great with stuff
like that, so I just end up
making it up in the moment.
- Yeah. Actually I do, you just
made me think of something.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- When I was touring
and doing country music
I forgot the lyrics to
my own song that I wrote.
- It specifically the
ones you write, you write.
- [Julianne] Yeah. Yeah.
- What is that?
- I don't know.
- Yeah
- Like we weren't certain.
Like we had so many
ideas for maybe this line
that we couldn't remember
which one we went with.
Like, I don't know what happens, but
- [Julianne] Totally.
- It's the worst when it's your song.
Yeah, and then you're just like, you sing.
- [Julianne] Yeah.
- Or like, I meant to do this yeah.